multiplication d'attentats ces derniers
jours à paris un cinéma et un homme
politique visé cette nuit de
l'utilisation des hôpitaux publics pour
des consultations privées l'enquète
d'antenne 2 accord au sommet de l'opep
les prix du pétrole seront gelés jusqu'à
la fin 90 et puis coup de théâtre au
procès de grenoble joël may tensio à
vous les trois crimes qui lui sont
reprochés à messieurs bonsoir avant de
développer tous ses titres au venons
juste un instant sur cette affaire de
sous marin soviétique dans les eaux
suédoises car voilà qu'on a trouvé un
autre
hier soir vous l'avez vu le premier
était mal en point il était échoué comme
une baleine en détresse sur la place et
bien voilà que maman baleine est allé
récupérer son petit baleineau un autre
sous-marin road en surface cette fois
dans les eaux territoriales suédoises du
gouvernement suédois se fâche les
relations entre les deux pays se tendent
patrick simpson jones il semblerait donc
que ce sous marin attaque soviétique ce
soit bien échoué pendant une mission
d'espionnage c'est en tout cas l'avis de
la suède qui n'hésite pas à qualifier
cet acte comme étant je cite la plus
grande violation de frontière suédoise
depuis la dernière
rappelons que le whisky 137 et oui vous
avez bien entendu car c'est le nom
soviétique de ce sous-marin s'est échoué
près de l'une des deux plus grandes
bases navales du pays les suédois se
sont habitués à ces violations car en
1981 leurs eaux territoriales ont été
violées 13 fois tant par les navires de
l'otan que par ceux du pacte de varsovie
mais jamais d'une façon aussi flagrante
aujourd'hui même deux jours après cette
mésaventure on a perçu le périscope de
ce qu'on croit être un deuxième
sous-marin soviétique qui semblerait
être venu aux nouvelles choses
dangereuses car depuis 74 lady
sous-marin connus qui ont été
officiellement repérés ont vu la marine
suédoise réagir violemment souvent en
lançant des charges sous marine de ce
monde l'ambassadeur du rs est à
stockholm michael ngako fleuve a été
convoqué par le gouvernement suédois
afin de fournir des explications
on lui a opposé une fin de non recevoir
catégorique à sa demande de faire
remettre le bâtiment à flot par les
spécialistes de la marine soviétique
difficile ce soir de trouver un lien
entre les différents attentats qui
depuis quelques jours réveil paris la
nuit
avant-hier on s'en était pris un
restaurant célèbre puis à la sortie d'un
cinéma n'y pas eu de victime mais la
nuit dernière c'était plus grave la
bombe a éclaté cette fois à l'intérieur
d'une salle de cinéma pendant la
projection
plus grave encore peut-être tentative
d'attentât contre le maire centriste de
clamart jean frontenaud qui a failli
être atteint par l'explosion d'une
grenade
dans les trois cas pas d'explication
françois corner
il était 23h 15 hier soir boulevard des
italiens dans l'une des trois salles du
cinéma gaumont une explosion de faible
intensité détruisait un fauteuil vide
trois spectateurs été commotionné par la
déflagration attentat revendiqué par
deux correspondants anonymes se
réclamant de deux organisations jusqu'à
présent inconnu septembre français armée
de libération kanak ce matin à clamart
un colis piégé était déposée d'avancé le
maire de la ville
j'ai aperçu une petite pochette
d'écoliers genre porte crayons
voyez-vous qui étaient placés là sous
cette forme je me suis dit 'ça dû
échapper une voiture et ça a été
repoussée ici alors je suis venu je n'ai
tiré pour la prendre
j'ai senti qu'elle était accroché alors
la sentence est résistance j'ai aperçu
la grenade qui sortait de la petite
pochette
j'ai vu la petite étincelle de la lune
gaz vous voyez quelque chose de gens
alors là j'ai dit à plus de questions ce
truc est très dangereux et je suis parti
je le dis comme un lapin jusqu'au bout
de cette allée ou rendu à à cet endroit
où il est rendu à cet endroit et n'ayant
pas tourner le dos
j'ai j'ai entendu avec attention 375
attentats à l'explosif en france dont 97
pour la région parisienne ont été
recensés depuis le début de l'année ceux
des derniers jours n'ont pas de mobile
apparent
c'est ce qui est le plus inquiétant ce
matin sa sortie de l'elysée où il était
reçu par le chef de l'état le préfet de
police a refusé de répondre aux
questions concernant ces explosions dont
je veux pas faire de déclaration
il ne serait absolument pas des clés sur
les origines de ces attentats
disons que j'ai pas de déclaration
particulière à faire sur le sujet je
vous prie de m'en excuser
plus que leur gravité c'est en fait la
multiplication de ces attentats qui
intrigue la police les enquêteurs sont
convaincus que ces actions ont un lien
entre elles et qu'elles tendent pas
créer un climat d'insécurité
quelques grincements de dents chez les
grands patrons de certains hôpitaux jack
ralite le miz la santé qui présentait
aujourd'hui son budget a fait savoir qu
entre autres mesures il allait
s'attaquer à certaines pratiques l on
pressent que l'on appelle la confusion
du secteur privé et du secteur public à
savoir le fait que certains praticiens
consulte à titre privé dans les hôpitaux
une enquête incisive de daniel leconte
pas sûr que non
et qu'on se tape france est séparé ses
habitants c'est à dire en consultation
publique je ne peux pas être vu par lui
même impossible donc de voir le chef de
service dans cet hôpital de la
périphérie parisienne même constat dans
d'autres hôpitaux
lorsque par hasard le patron n'est pas
tout à fait inaccessibles les délais de
rendez-vous sont largement dissuasif
en cas d'hospitalisation le patient qui
choisit un lit privé devra payer 25 % en
plus pour à peu près les mêmes
prestations
les soins médicaux sont exactement les
mêmes dans tout mon service et je le
pense dans tous les services
hospitaliers comporte un service privé
le seul avantage de ce malade qu'il est
seul dans sa chambre et d'autre part
c'est qu'il a une relation plus directe
avec celui qui le soignent qu'il a
consultés qu'ils opèrent il est sûr
d'être suivi exactement par le médecin
qui l'a choisi l'impression qu'en payant
une consultation privée où vous serez
mieux soigner en s'occupant mieux vous
et puis que oui que je suis sûr d'avoir
me garder alors que si je vais dans un
hôpital public
je veux avoir importé docteur si vous
avez de l'autre côté vous n'êtes pas sûr
de l'avoir c'est ça la vraie raison il y
à ce que vous appelez riche et quand
quelques fois des exigences de soient
plus attentifs que d'eau prenez soin
infirmier ne change pas mais il est pour
eux important que le médecin soit plus
disponibles puissent tous les jours
écouté leurs doléances répondre à leurs
craintes bref ils ont quelquefois des
besoins psychologiques supérieur à
d'autres personnes les portes sont ici
de la même couleur elle sépare pourtant
le privé du public seule différence la
chambre individuelle une salles
d'attentes descente et une disponibilité
plus grand du personnel hospitalier
un personnel des équipements financés
par le service public est utilisé à des
fins privées d'un concrètement
on a une salle où il ya vingt malades il
y en a cinq qui sont en secteur privé on
est une infirmière pour les 15 et une
pour les 5es qui est-ce qui paye ses
infirmières c'est la sécurité sociale
par le biais de fruits de journée c'est
à dire qu'il ya un véritable
détournement de fonds public vers le
privé et les seuls en tirer profit
ne sont pas les malades ni l'hôpital ou
alors très simplement ce qu'ils en
tirent privés sont les professeurs
agrégés c'est à dire ceux déjà qu'ils
ont les plus hauts revenus
à l'hôpital le 1er janvier 1982 il n'y
aura plus de secteur privé dans les
hôpitaux publics suite de la discussion
budgétaire à l'assemblée aujourd'hui
l'impôt sur la fortune finalement les
oeuvres d'art ne seront pas incluses
dans le champ de l'impôt il ya donc
exonérations mais les droits sur les
opérations des changes ont augmenté de
50% a dit laurent fabius démission des
deux patrons du cnrs le centre national
de la recherche scientifique le
directeur général jacques du clain et
puis tout à l'heure le président
lui-même charles thibault était en
conflit avec jean pierre chevènement
ministre de la recherche qui voulait la
démission de l'un de leur directeur puis
un élément nouveau dans la sphère de
paris va la faire la scission de la
filiale suisse c'est l'humanité qui
publie ce matin un document que
décortique maintenant philippe sassier
mais ce document même le voici
publié par l'humanité les parfaitement
authentique il s'agit de la
régularisation d'un acte de vente en
fait un bordereau de paiement ce
document prouve que paribas a vendu à
une société étrangère les actions ses
filiales paribas suisse
voici le chiffre à retenir 325 mille
actions de paribas suisse pour un
montant de 390 millions de francs
environ 39 milliards de centimes si vous
voulez ont ainsi été cédés
alors que s'est-il passé voilà ce qu'en
simplifiant on peut dire des histoires à
raconter
le 9 octobre dernier une société suisse
par gay ça propose d'acheter paribas
suisse pour cela elle demande aux
actionnaires étrangers de celle-ci
d'échanger leurs actions contre des
actions de pargues et ça c'est ce que
l'on appelle en langage financier une
opération publique des changes une op
pour faciliter cette opération qui
devait la déposséder de paribas suisse
est bien la maison mère française a fait
sortir 2
france les actions de sa filiale
helvétique
aujourd'hui donc paribas ce fils tu lui
appartient plus et n'est plus nationale
is able or c'est un établissement
important qui occupe environ le 20e rang
parmi les banques suisses est ce qu'on
peut dire quel délit alors depuis hier
un décret interdit aux banques
nationales is able d'effectuer ce genre
d'opération sans la permission des
pouvoirs publics avant c'est vrai il y
avait un vide juridique donc pas de
délit le bordereau publié par l'humanité
est datée du 16 octobre mais dès le mois
de juillet jacques delors avait demandé
aux banques d'avertir les pouvoirs
publics lorsqu'elle désirez effectuer ce
genre d'opération or c'est ce que n'a
pas fait le président démissionnaire de
paribas pierre moussa de même que
paribas n'a pas averti le chargé de
mission du gouvernement auprès diable
qu'est ce que peut faire le gone
mascarade et des poursuites par faire
passer la ksa c'est la question alors le
conseil d'administration de paribas n'a
pas été lui non plus tenu au cul rond au
courant la question au nom de savoir
s'il ya ou non infractions là les avis
divergent le gouvernement semble-t-il
pour le moement cherche à faire ni aux
pressions plus ou moins discrètement sur
le conseil d'administration pour arriver
à annuler cette vente alors yat-il
poursuites judiciaires l'eau si on en
parle mais tout le monde est très
discret en tout cas il s'agit d'un
épisode important de la guerre que les
milieux financiers belges suisses et
peut être demain américain déclenche
contre les nationalisations des banques
françaises qui ont les intérêts à
l'étranger ainsi aujourd'hui on a appris
que la filiale belge de paribas avait
suivi le même chemin que la filiale
suisse on peut s'attendre à pas mal de
péripéties dans les jours qui viennent
ce soir il ya plein de rumeurs qui
circulent dans paris c'est un peu faim
dans les histoires financière c'est un
petit peu comme dans les romans
policiers ainsi on disait mais été
démenti que la filiale de paribas
luxembourg avait elle aussi filiale
anglaise encore une fois ces éléments
clés comme la suisse on parle beaucoup
en tout cas d'une descente que la douane
a effectué il y aura bientôt un an en
novembre dernier au siège parisien de
paribas il paraît que les douaniers
auraient mis la main sur des documents
croustillant penses tu en perds mon roi
a cherché une nouvelle fois séduire les
chefs d'entreprise il était l'invité du
nouvel économiste en fin d'après midi
nouvel économiste qui a élu olivier le
surf manager de l'année 80 olive et le
surf et pdg de lafarge premier groupe
cimentier français le troisième mondial
et il sera demain l'invité d'antenne de
mise
un accord à genève il ya moins d'une
heure sur le prix du pétrole les 13 pays
de l'opep sont tombés d'accord donc sur
un plan un prix plancher de 34 dollar
par baril et un prix plafond de 38
dollars l'opep qui par ailleurs et c'est
important a décidé de geler les prix du
pétrole jusqu'à la fin 82 jean claude
renaud au téléphone car la nouvelle
vient tout juste de tomber le foie
on ne s'était pas trompé les pays de
l'opep été condamnés à s'entendre
à genève la fin de la bagarre entre les
partisans du pétrole à prix modérés
comme les saoudiens et les partisans du
pétrole cher comme la libye ou l'algérie
l'accord vient d'être signé
premier point le bruit blanc fait du
baril sera désormais de 34 dollars cela
signifie que le bruit saoudien a ajouté
deux dollars de plus par baril et cela
signifie donc pour la france y est fait
à l'arabie saoudite de la moitié de son
pétrole
une augmentation de la facture
pétrolière d'environ 4 milliards de
francs pour l'automobile y est cela se
traduira à la pompe par une hausse des
carburants de 3 à 5 centimes deuxième
point de l'accord réalisé ce soir à
genève ibrim payés aux producteurs sont
le pétrole est de meilleure qualité et
breeam ne devrait pas excéder 4 dollars
le prix maximum du baril et entités à 38
dollars
enfin dernier point le prix du pétrole
devrait être gelé jusqu'à la fin de 82
est une bonne nouvelle était une
garantie pour les pays consommateurs
il ne devrait plus y avoir de surprise
pendant tout quoi un an
c'est une relative bonne nouvelle par
exemple pour l'aviation qui ne se
portent pas du tout bien en ce moment là
lui à cannes du congrès les
transporteurs aériens nationaux toutes
les grandes compagnies sont en déficit
et suppose carburant qui prend trop
d'importance le cas limite c'est celui
de concorde qui consommaient beaucoup et
bien au terme de la visite que le
ministre en sports charles fiterman a
entrepris ce matin
londres il apparaît que contrairement à
ce qu'on avait pu dire un moment
l'avenir de concorde n'est pas menacée
dans l'immédiat
betty du rose s'est saisi du dossier
côté britannique
essayez donc dernier vol du concorde
poignardé par les américains pour des
raisons politiques
la hausse du coût des carburants lui
fait rater le rendez-vous du progrès qui
l'avait alors histoire
edo concorde du londres new york
quotidien ligne de loin la plus
fréquentée les trois avions hebdomadaire
sur washington s'envole rarement avec
leurs 100 passagers très exactement
moitié moins du nécessaire pour en
assurer la rentabilité
un volant de clientèle trop restreint
hommes d'affaires pressés par le temps
cadres supérieurs de grosses entreprises
seules capables de payer 22 1176 francs
pour un aller retour sur new york
en moins de quatre heures en fait j'ai
un rendez vous d'affaires très important
dans 82 york et pour moi c'est la seule
façon d'y être quelle est leur d'oise du
crecq touche de ses premiers
balbutiements aux années 80 le programme
concorde s'élèvent à 35 milliards de
francs
épongez équitablement par les deux pays
mais les causes sont loin d'être seuls d
année dernière les lignes concorde d'air
france auront coûté 335 millions de
francs motif ils couverts à 90% par
l'état
les britanniques elle s'en tire mieux
avec une perte annuelle pour la même
période des 60 millions de francs
financé seulement à 50% par le
contribuable d'outre-manche la british
airways rentabiliser eux c'est au corps
la clientèle à 80% américaine s'envolent
plus souvent vers londres que vers paris
permettant ainsi à la compagnie anglaise
de majorer de 6000 francs par rapport
aux prix air france le billet au camp de
britanniques
donc le londres new york gagne de
l'argent 44 millions de francs l'année
immédiatement il est vrai cri yachts et
de moitié par les critiques de la ligue
landru washington qui paraît qu'il
pourrait se porter mieux avec une
extension sur miami à l'étude actuelle
si le gouvernement britannique at il
affirmé dans un livre blanc
en réponse aux violentes critiques d'un
rapport parlementaire sur le coup de
concorde la mort de l'avion coûterait
plus cher que sa survie
462 millions de francs contre 222 en le
laissant venu c'est un merveilleux
engins mais cette machine prestigieuses
ne deviendra jamais une bonne affaire
dès qu'un gène en cause de la hausse des
carburants la cause des nuisances
causées l'environnement ni concorde
qu'aucun autre supersonique nom de
l'avenir que much eau propre et chemin
un beau corps d'anglais plus imaginatifs
que son jumeau français par exemple
en projet la location de deux avions
voué au hangar à la federal express une
entreprise de messagerie américaine
persuadé de rentabiliser les vols en
remplissant concorde de lettres et de
paquets pressé de traverser l'espace
aérien transatlantique avions cargo quel
avenir pour l'oiseau le plus rapide du
monde
voulue par charles de gaulle et dont
françois mitterrand parle comme d'une
remarquable réussite technique
manifestation des employés des banques
ce matin à paris plusieurs remis et
d'employés ont répondu à l'appel de la
cgt mais la journée nationale de grève
de 24 heures avait été organisée par les
quatre grandes centrales syndicales pour
appuyer des revendications salariales
grève également dans les caisses
d'epargne l'écureuil augmentation des
prix chez peugeot et talbot augmentation
effective dès maintenant +3 9%
et puis ces propos les deux mon maire en
réponse à charles fiterman qui avait
critiqué la grève des cheminots de
villeneuve saint georges
il sait plus comporter en misant
communiste quand ministre d'état at il
dit sur un mc coûte p4 tout à l'heure en
fin d'après midi la cour d'assises de
grenoble joël matt anciaux a reconnu au
terme d'une audience dramatique et trois
crimes qui lui sont imputés
il s'est même proposé d'aller avec les
policiers à l'endroit où et lens vit
l'une de ses victimes un endroit qu'on
avait jamais découverts depuis cinq ans
compte rendu d'audience
paul lefèvre tout à l'heure matencio à
craquer blême la voix sourde il a dit je
sais où est le corps d'olga noailles
cenco emmenez-moi sur les lieux et je
vous montrerai coup de théâtre une salle
bloqué par l'émotion et la stupéfaction
de battre le président robert fabre
matencio reconnaissez-vous être le
meurtrier de dommery cenco encore un
silence puis matencio fait huit la tête
matencio reconnaissez-vous être le
meurtrier de christian leroy et du
muriel ferrari encore un lui pour la
première fois donc il avoue pour la
première fois ils semblent humain
sensible à quelque chose
le procès s'est arrêté la cour et les
jurés vont aller sur place tenter de
retrouver la dépouille d'oldbury cenco
c'est la loi mais matencio et l'homme
qui jusqu'à présent a toujours menti
l'at il fait encore ce soir
autre procès à sensation celui de roger
knobelspiess à rouen aujourd'hui un
réquisitoire un réquisitoire 10 sont
modérés côté rien ou tracera un portrait
du procureur dans le journal de jacques
mannino à 23h à l'étranger tout d'abord
la situation au tchad et le gouvernement
a démenti tout à l'heure toute rumeur de
coup d'état la situation à n'djamena et
est donc tout à fait calme mais le
numéro deux libyen le commandant jalloud
dessus sur place a accusé la france d'
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
tchadienne ce qui ne manque pas de
piquant de la part d'un homme qui
assisté hier à lui-même au conseil des
ministres tchadien philippe rochot il
c'est justement pour ça parce qu'il
assistait au conseil des ministres du
tchad et que cela avait provoqué un
vaste déploiement de forces libyennes
dans la capitale qu'on a cru justement
un coup d'état et même la population ne
s'y est pas trompé puisque elle a
traversé le fleuve chari pour aller se
réfugier au cameroun de crainte
justement d'assister un coup d'état
alors si le commandant jalloud a dénoncé
la politique de la france c'est qu'elle
est en contradiction avec celle de la
libye la libye vous savez occupe cette
fameuse région la bande d'aozou et livre
des armes à ses partisans que monsieur
armée das ils représentaient au sein du
gouvernement tchadien et puis la libye
entretient au tchad
un contingent de quelques 4000 à 5000
soldats la france de son côté veut
renforcer l'autorité légale c'est-à-dire
celle de monsieur goukouni oueddei qu
actuellement chef du gouvernement alors
elle envoie donc une aide logistique au
tchad et elle plaide en faveur de
l'envoi d'une force neutre inter
africaine pour remplacer les libyens or
c'est aussi la politique de l'eau via
l'organisation de l'unité africaine et
c'est pour ça que le colonel kadhafi ne
devrait pas augmenter sa pression sur le
chat puisque en juillet prochain c'est
lui même qui doit accueillir à tripoli
le sommet de l'oua et il ne veut pas se
trouver isolées précisément sur la scène
africaine elle giscardien françois
léotard a condamné aujourd'hui ce qu'il
appelle l'incohérence extravagantes de
la politique française au tchad
belle victoire de ronald reagan hier
soir il a obtenu du sénat américain
l'accord de livraison des avions awacs
ce qu'a aussitôt déploré l'homme en
israël y un accord de justesse 52
48 mais un beau sujet de satisfaction
pour le président un mec edouard là un
coup de téléphone du leader de la
majorité du sénat qui a dû faire bien
plaisir à ronald reagan surtout lorsque
l'on sait que ce vote était considéré
comme un test pour l'homme que l'on a
souvent qualifié si d'amateurs en
matière de politique étrangère et très
habilement dès qu'il a eu le résultat du
vote cette nuit donc ronald reagan a
voulu rassurer ceux qui se sentaient le
plus visé par cette vente à l'arabie
séoudite à savoir les israéliens et on
murmure ici que déjà des contreparties
sont prévus un escadron de chasseurs qui
serait très vite libre et à israël
de quoi rassurer en partie les
responsables de la communauté juive
américaine dont les réactions étaient ce
matin étonnamment modéré ou et mat
en deux mots est ce que vous croyez
encore au soutien de l'américain sera
une tour d' de still believe in d
administration support of israel pc
washington décidé de retirer de l'egypte
les deux awacs qui avait été envoyé au
lendemain de l'assassinât du président
sadate un nouveau premier ministre pour
l'iran monsieur mir hossein moussavi
dont l'investiture a été accordé par le
parlement
et puis les suites de la déchéance de
stanislaw kania ancien numéro un
polonais bien il n'est plus aujourd'hui
même membre du bureau politique
en sport sachez tout d'abord qu'en
tennis à la surprise générale borg a été
battu dans le tournoi de tokyo est battu
largement il était battu e 6 3 6 1 par
la mecque team geeks et puis en football
le retour du bordelais tigana qui
manquait cruellement et à son équipe et
à l'équipe de france qui va rejouer donc
dès la semaine prochaine contre hambourg
en match de l'uefa et a tenu sa promesse
six semaines après son opération des
adducteurs jean tigana est de retour
éloigné du championnat de france de la
coupe d'europe et de l'équipe de france
depuis le 11 août dernier
l'international bordelais est exact à
son rendez vous dès demain soir il va
disputer avec son club la 15e journée du
championnat
pour sa rentrée et tigana va être
confronté au paris saint germain
une équipe parisienne tout auréolé d'un
large succès sur nantes mardi dernier
une rentrée qui vient à point nommé
tigana jouera bien sûr le match retour
de coupe d'europe
hambourg bordeaux peut être aussi fera
t-il parti du milieu de terrain de
l'équipe de france qui doit disputer ce
match si important contre la hollande le
18 novembre prochain
les résultats du quarté le 10 est le 2
le 21 et le 22 ou ne risquez rien devoir
parce que rien ne s'est inscrit sur
votre écran je vais vous dire quand même
ce que ça va vous rapporter dans l'ordre
vérifie que fait bien pour 1 franc
devant vous et c'est pour 1 franc lors
de multiples bars max avec chose comme
300 mille francs à peu près donc si vous
avez touché le bon quartz est à une
somme record et un peu plus de 25000
francs dans un ordre différent donc je
répète pour ceux qui n'ont pas entendu
17,2 21 et 22 avec alain gillot-pétré
maintenant la météo demain
vous savez ce que je vais vous dire la
même chose que vous disait laurent
hilaire demain garder votre parapluie et
oui c'est comme cela nous n'en finissons
pas une série de perturbations nous
arrive venus de l'atlantique mais ces
perturbations nous apporte aussi la
douceur en effet les extrêmes de
température relevée à 13h par la
multinationale nous indiquait qu'il
faisait 10 degrés à dijon
c'était le minimum et le maximum 19
degrés à ajaccio ajaccio qui est
derrière moi
la prévision pour demain région par
région vous le voyez au nord d'une ligne
qui va de kirène ils ont de royan à
genève pour être précis on n'est pas 10
kilomètres près et bien le temps sera
très nuageux avec des pluies
intermittentes mais il fera doux les
vents souffleront d'ouest/nord-ouest
plus forts près de la manche au sud de
cette ligne est bien encore quelques
averses résiduelles sur les alpes et
l'extrême sud est du pays
mais tout cela s'arrangera dans la
journée et après dissipation des brumes
matinales
il devrait y avoir de belles éclaircies
avec tout de même quelques passages
nuageux mais des nuages des nuages
d'altitude relativement la prévision de
température pour demain maintenant ville
par ville représentatif de la région du
mont owl's head aujourd'hui le matin de
7 à 10 degrés et l'après midi de 12 à 20
degrés c'est assez doux pour assez doux
pour l'époque contenu de ces
températures et bien l'année conseil de
l' agence pour les économies d'énergie
et c'est qu'on s'est bien entendu vous
connaissez le code en rouge ou enfoncez
vous pouvez chauffer en blanc ce n'est
pas la peine est en pointillé
eh bien vous faites comme vous voulez de
façon intermittente enfin notre essai
mérite pour demain vendredi 30 octobre
et relevé
coucher du soleil 7h35 17h33 et la sat
bienvenus j'aurais dû commencer par sa
voix la bomba bienvenue à jacques merino
qui présentera donc le journal vers
23h15 et puis antenne de midi demain et
bien fip l'approuvera donc olivier le
cercle pdg des ciments la marche de
notre honte si vous le voulez bien
demain à 20 heures
bonne soirée